[Music]
and here comes Joe moly anew Oh
submitted by my king you must do this
okay what happened almost an entire town
in Oregon is on sale for 3.5 million
dollars
the whole town set of GoFundMe is it the
physical like land of the whole town or
you own the land and the people and the
houses in it yeah it's a Postell part of
the United States yeah what is that what
do you get to own after you pay the
price I know I was curious to like how I
didn't know you can own a whole town
like that but what I found out is that
this there are unincorporated areas in
the country that can be privately owned
and that's the case here Oh with us with
3.5 million it includes six houses a
general store and gas station land under
the post office can't own a post office
politics amount yeah undeveloped lot
which is about two hundred and fifty six
acres damn huge in 29 plot you get water
right and infrastructure such as high
sidewalks fire hydrants and power
station what about the sheriff station I
don't I don't think that I am curious
what about the inhabitants of this town
do they just up and leave no okay so
actually first of all I'm gonna show you
guys a video this is crazy
it's like real-life monopoly there's a
lot of people that can afford them
yeah it's only 3.5 million is it I gotta
pay for it all or can I don't pay it
they're big zero money down I could do
it right now I'm not sure the terms but
here we go
I love the voiceover
dramatic beginning of the hormone a
killer organ is an unincorporated
centrally located rural community
nestled between the coastal and the
Cascade Mountain Range in southwestern
working what a nice place the owners of
this extraordinary opportunity to find
the ability to structure a wide variety
of examples excellence structures and
password we can play fence 80 real-life
South on forever the tiller area is
bordered by the majestic on Guam
National Forest
[Music]
region is a vast variety of fish and
wildlife for them and recreational
options driving for me I like it just
what keep right now mm-hmm River and
help save water branch parallel stream
and advocates passed two million board
feet of included merchant lieutenant
[Music]
a continual but and then Ryan weekend
there's a dead body because it sounds
like like a horror movie trailer
you know how they started really nice he
has all of a sudden you see a dead
person to stake to a [ __ ] tree with
their neck just like a lot oh we just
pitch in get that place we have our own
place I wouldn't know what to do and
then we would make a real life theme
park hmm
we just move everything that we have
there and then don't come and visit and
then they can take pictures with us at
the wax museum not a version of that wax
yeah because we're going to be busy
running [ __ ] you know and fly fishing
and enjoying the land and relaxing and
playing like that you know what now I
know why cults have their own compounds
in the middle of nowhere it's fun jamya
sounds like a cult I mean I don't know
what to do when you own a plot of what
is your responsibilities like what is
what what you won't do
I think it's like owning a house but
it's just a really really really really
big as you would you would be man and
out you never played sin see I love Sin
City for me as you kept [ __ ] up my
place no man I assume you've got to turn
off the natural disasters option like
this but I don't like this God says when
yeah so this town uh so that post office
it was opened back in 1902 and in that
time there were a lot of miners and
loggers and ranchers and families that
flock to that town because it was a once
bustling logging community this is what
it looked like back in 1930 some photos
it's like the market where look like the
finest girl in town the best loja so
yeah it's like some old donut
photographers son that's will let in too
much like look at all that light that
pull it in I don't know we have that
[ __ ] thing with a booth within the
need to change the gold oh yeah
both the bold and everything
once it was first taking business away
it's been weathered yeah maybe so yeah
these are a lot of the people that lived
in that could be us guys
can you imagine what did the rabbit
2,000 people know this photographer they
use the very first camera ever you know
fish city and photographer I'll be done
all I'm saying is nature is the [ __ ]
I like nature's it all you think is it
that's all I'm saying this whole time
don't you want to be in the nature where
you see the tree and then the waters
just like on the river and it makes you
want to pee and then I like nature but
when I see that I also see insanity cuz
I will [ __ ] go crazy and I can't be
doing that living there everything like
I could do it for them all where's the
traction like I need I could probably do
it for about a couple months and then
I'd be like I need to eat some real food
I think I see suspicious you went insane
oh yeah I'm on that get to the best
ingredients [ __ ] shoot a bear for you
do you ever have bear steak before
oh not but who's gonna make soondubu
yeah what uh we need some modern
culinary creations of veneer and we have
eat24
we got GrubHub probably not up camera
they could send it to a grub about
there's a [ __ ] pair bringing you a
salmon it is actually is they have a lot
of berries near there and they're saying
that they're so you asked about the
people there right 235 people still live
in that area and they're all brothers
and sisters and they're crazy
no this isn't West Virginia G this is
Oregon these are all the smart people
that survived the Oregon Trail the
people that live near there they're
about so there's they're all like
scattered between the mountains so it's
just people that live in the surrounding
area but what's on sale it's like the
downtown of that area and so people
really they still heavily rely on that
town because that's where they go and
they meet up like every Friday the
but the local church oh and are saying
that the the nearest phone signal is
about a 30 minute drive Oh what my cell
phone signal helper - holy [ __ ]
that's what I mean gnome on it I don't
want it keep your talk you go down hold
on you're like I'm like on the organ
trail and we need to shoot buffaloes to
last us a long time for the rest of your
life I wanna I want to feel working
you're lazy
we're working out there wasn't we me and
my town folk mmm like you know what I'm
working my brain I'm doing the simcity
[ __ ] I'm thinking of all the plans and
all that stuff and the cool thing is I
get to wear a red checkered plaid shirt
with overalls and we could be hanging
and talking about the crop this year you
guys draw a scene on here yeah can you
honestly look like that for the rest of
your life static [ __ ] I don't know I
don't know we're not in West Virginia
Joe what's your dunya has Internet
I do love nature though like I feel good
just being outdoors in nature 24/7 I
love it you love it because you know
you're going to come back to this dope
ass place no if I had a choice I
wouldn't want to be trapped indoors all
day without internet I don't think we're
talked about being trapped indoors being
in a city because we should be in a city
and be outside you're in steady when you
want to get some dope ramen you'll get
some dope Ramat you know ain't no ramen
over there I think you're the person
that doesn't like eating the same [ __ ]
every day
it can't be Buffalo every day your
beauty Buffalo every day you are lazy
probably the same thing every day you
like the modern amenities that a city
brings give me that life but with nature
then we got the best enough this is what
you were telling the downtown of pillar
organ no thank you
it's a little too north for me honestly
I'm just being offered optimistic
because uh if that was in Hawaii peace
guys now they're saying that there are
already a lot of potential buyers with
the remaining anonymous and so just the
people and bears
resolving are you the kind of The
Bachelor know what the [ __ ] you mean
with the help it
yeah but they're um yeah I forgot to
mention to that the elementary school is
also for sale or an additional for pedal
bar fart oh yeah why can't you Sousa are
subtle yeah it just peaked
how many kids that [ __ ] looks like three
kids go there he's owning it yeah so
that might help the elementary school is
being sold separately for 350 Pepin a
teacher Tiffany if I own a [ __ ]
I can build all the amenities that I
want to yeah you can it's gonna be
[ __ ] expensive to bring cell phone
wire in there tell each other's hair I
just want a nature I want the both how
do you get both where's a place in the
world that has both words like you can
get it there but just not that area yeah
you got the paper I feel like we can you
spend 3.2 million to buy it or whatever
I think we need to drop another 10
million to develop it exactly alright
wait we more than that cost like half a
billion dollars do just to develop it
yes I like fully fully develop a cable
lines so that there's a cell phone
satellite tower that you can actually
get signal stuff like I don't even bring
tractors into the start like building
other buildings on you just the
logistics is crazy too much work
what about just moving to a place that
has both 99 where is the place like that
so I'm saying la you can't you can but
you got to be a believer in there
infinitely a billionaire so your honor
are you looking for a place a little bit
less City than Ellen and more nature I
don't mind the downtown I just want to
have easy access to nature let me go to
ten minutes away baby also things like
that altered it is like that yeah
Pasadena City and there's no like the
suburbs anyone downtown all you want
downtown it and nature like dogs a
minimal I wish another guy huh yeah I
think so peace out you better not be
missing no just kidding news uploads so
go down and subscribe for our channel so
you can see more video okay
and there's another one up here check it
out
[Music]